i wondered  why you feel hal is more relevant than  ever right now  i mean i don't think of it in terms of  right now  because for me it's just always  i uh  you know there's something about those  movies you have a very uh visceral  emotional connection to them and they  stay with you and haunt you forever  which i was reminded  uh of as i cried while uh we heard those  songs again and i thought how many times  have i cried to those songs to that  movie  and my wife leslie who's here who when i  first met her let me know right away  that she's watched that movie hundreds  and hundreds of times which i didn't  know if i should be concerned about or  not  but i see him as  he's the bar  you know when when we work you know we  dream that we can ever make anything as  good as those movies and we ultimately  fail every time out  everything i've done has been a bad  version of one of those  but i'll keep trying  you